Film Courage: I know we’re talking about
writing being very practical and business-like
but it sounds like you really do have to be
your own middle-manager or boss.
The stress and unromantic notion of deadlines,
how is this?
Screenwriter Christine Conradt: Unromantic
notion!
I love that phrase.
Deadlines are the things that separate someone
who writes for a hobby from someone who writes
for a living and those are two very different
things.
There is a stress obviously to deadlines but
there is also a relief to deadlines in that
once you’re done with this project it’s
done.
Once it shoots, you’re off of it.
Otherwise when it’s your hobby, it’s sort
of this project that you can work on forever,
sometimes people do work on them forever.
So knowing that you are going to get to the
finish line and then move on to the next thing
helps keep you looking forward and I actually
really enjoy that.
Once of the things I didn’t like about the
YMCA was dealing with the same issues over
and over, the same personnel issues.
You know the same two people that you’re
counseling three months ago are back in your
office and we’re talking about this again.
The same budgets every quarter, you’re putting
them together again.
It got really boring.
For me, I love going full force into one project
and then now I’m done.
I can forget about it and now I am full force
into the next thing.
So that’s the beauty of deadlines.
Film Courage: Right, because I know you mentioned
you didn’t totally want a day job and I
get that because it is a lot of the same…whatever
the dynamic is there.
But then there are new problems with being
on your own because there is like this free
fall that could happen if you keep yourself
on track (which it sounds like you’re excellent
at).
Christine Conradt: I try to be.
Film Courage: Absolutely.
It sounds like it.
That’s a [major] skill in itself, though.
Christine Conradt: That is a part you really
have to develop and (again) I always tell
writers this, you’ve got to view this…because
everyone sees writing as their dream job.
And they have this fantasy that they get up
in the morning and they are still in their
pajamas and they’re petting their cats and
they’re writing for two hours and it’s
a wonderful existence.
And it can be whatever you want it to be.
You’re obviously in control of it.
But you have to approach it like a business.
You’re doing it not just because you love
it anymore but also to make money.
There’s that whole other component and if
you can balance them right you can have both.
You can still love it and you can still make
money.
But the money part is a big part of it because
we all have bills to pay.
So if that’s not for you, then keep it a
hobby and enjoy the process of writing two
pages a day if that’s what you like to do.
That luxury goes as soon as it becomes a profession.